everybody what is going on welcome to
the 11th Cavey basics tutorial video in
this video we're gonna be talking about
adding our I don't know drawing
application to this little application
here and using the buttons to go back
and forth between the application and
say the home screen or whatever you
could envision it being a game or I
don't know stock prices or what pretty
much whatever you wanted so this is what
we left off with and now basically this
will be our this will be our home screen
and then we'll rename next screen to be
I don't know draw okay
so let's close out of this and go ahead
and get started so this is actually
going to be fairly simplistic I've now
I'm using main to main to cavies I'm
gonna change this the loader to main to
now KB uh and that should be the only
thing to change and anyway moving on so
how do we actually make these changes
and move forward so first we're going to
need our actual drawing applications so
I'm just gonna rewrite it it's a pretty
quick right anyways so we had a class it
was we'll call that we call it painter I
guess or I think we called it draw or
something before and it actually needs
to inherit from widget which we haven't
imported so let's actually make our
theme necessary imports as well so first
we want to have from TV UI x dot widget
we're going to import widget then we
need we're also going to need line and
we'll be using buttons and we'll really
use the button in here most likely I
think we'll get a way out without
importing button so then from k V dot
graphics import line X let's capital L
line okay so now we're ready to continue
on with our painter inheriting from
widget and now we're going to define the
on touch down so again ask yourself
where does on touch down actually come
from is that our code or their code next
self touch again is that like my code or
is that their code
then we're going to say with self dot
canvas more is that my coder they're
good touch UT and then the element here
that we want is line equals capital line
and then the points are equal to touch X
and touch whoops
touch dot y and uh if this feels like
it's going too fast for you go back like
three tutorials I think is where we
actually built this originally so you
can go back there and see how that how
it was done if you want more explanation
there then again we have on defined on
underscore touch underscore move self
dot ourself comma touch and touch UD
line dot points plus equals and touch
XCOM on touch why okay and that's
basically it we're not gonna write
anything else here this should all be
acceptable so this is our little widget
right same widget that we had before and
now what we want to do is add this
widget to our kind of screen changing
that we've already got so we want this
widget painter in another screen but we
actually don't have to do that via this
file we're going to do it via the key V
file so in another screen we'll get rid
of button for now we'll eventually have
a but in there just to it but for now
we're not gonna have anything we're just
going to say name other and then we add
our fun painter class here so we should
just be able to say just painter nothing
more so it would be as if we were
actually adding the painter into another
screen down here but we're not really
but anyway so it's a painter widget and
we're adding it to another screen so
let's save that and run this and
hopefully this works out so we go to the
next screen and sure enough we are able
to
draw yay ok so that's how we were able
to add just a simple little widget that
we had built initially that widget was
just heading straight into this page but
this one obviously has sort of multiple
pages but now you might wonder ok at
what if we want to get back to the main
page like what if this was like a
settings page and you wanted the user to
be able to get back to the main page you
need to have another button on here so I
think that's what we'll do in the next
video we'll add a button to go kind of
back and forth kind of like we did
before only the button took up the whole
page and in fact there will be no new
code in the next videos for us adding a
button is concerned I encourage you to
go ahead and try to see if you can add a
button just a small button I think we'll
probably put ours up and maybe in the
top here to go back home but just try to
add your own small button and see if you
can and if you can't then obviously you
can still check the next video so
anyways that's what we'll do in the next
video so stay tuned for that if you guys
have any questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support in the subscriptions
until next time